hi I'm Eric Voss and Westworld season 2
on HBO has ended and we now finally know
what happens the remaining question is
when it happens and why is to Loras I
covered all the big questions coming out
of the finale and the post-credits scene
in my Indian explain video but here I'm
gonna break down the full Westworld
timeline adding on to what we already
know about the timeline from season 1
and of course spoiler warning if you
haven't seen all of season 2 so the big
thing to understand about season 2 is
that it split up into two primary
timelines from Bernards point of view
separated by two weeks timeline a shows
Bernard in the immediate aftermath of
Dolores massacre at the della Scala
timeline B shows Bernard two weeks after
that with scrambled memories joining the
dello security team the finale episode
catches up the events of timeline a to
the point where timeline B begins and
all explained exactly when each part of
the story fits but first let's start way
the beginning of everything and plug in
all of the new season 2 stuff into the
overall Westworld timeline so after
season 1 a video on the west-world
website briefly showed the present year
of the show as 2052
now that date was later removed but for
the sake of keeping track of all this
let's use that date as an anchor point
so season 1 established a three year pre
Westworld period during which ford and
arnold built the OG hosts including
Dolores during this time arnold held
secret sessions with Dolores resulting
in him ordering Dolores to kill him
season 2 re-examines this moment from
the Native American perspective with a
key chedda finding the aftermath of this
after this his people were reassigned
from a peaceful tribe to the violence
ghost nation now sometime after Arnold's
death Ford with Dolores help tried to
use data gathered on Arnold to build a
new version of him that resulted in
Bernard now I assume this would at least
be a generation later maybe around the
Year 2040 when employees who had worked
with Arnold were all gone and no one
left would recognize Bernards
resemblance to the parks founder the
west-world Park officially opened to the
public a few years after Arnold's death
and shortly after it opened a young
William first visited the park with
Logan around the year 2022 so all the
season 1 storylines involving Williams
journey with Logan and Dolores and
William
dark turn all happened around then
season 2 also shows a key cheetah
finding Logan shortly after William
deserted him season 2 also fills in
Williams rise in the Dell O's company
not long after his first visit maybe
around 2023 he brings his boss James
Dell O's to the park and he pitches its
true value a way to secretly collect
psychological data on human guests Delos
approves of this plan and Williams joins
the family marrying James's daughter
Juliet and conceiving a child with her
sometime in the years after James Delos
gets diagnosed with a terminal illness
and he has a permanent falling-out with
his son Logan which we saw in the final
episode in around 2027 Delos has a
retirement party now we know it was this
year because it was a few years after
Williams's daughter was born she appears
to be three or four in the scene and
yeah we can see that Delos is ill
meanwhile William has begun fidelity
experiments with an AI clone of Delos
who's pretty glitchy at the start
sometime in the years after this the
real James Delos dies of his illness in
the same year his wife dies of a stroke
and his son Logan dies of a drug
overdose meanwhile William repeatedly
visits the park trying to find meaning
through a relationship with Dolores
which could be some of what we see from
their scenes throughout season one but
eventually William gives up he meets
Dolores alone in the basement and he
says no I'm breaking up with you
and he reveals some early construction
of the forge and around this time akicha
de is found by Park Tech's who are
surprised to learn that he has been
alive for 10 years without dying once
here akita decides to begin spreading
the truth he's learned about the parks
secrets by hiding in the maze symbol
underneath scallops okay seven years
after Delos is death William meets with
Dallas's AI clone again and this host
version is a bit less glitchy this time
and is the first time that we see this
host version learned that his real self
is dead okay so now we jump forward
season 2 also shows us Williams wife
Juliet's suicide right before he returns
to the park as an old man as he is in
season 1 shortly after this suicide
William visits the AI clone of Delos one
last time he tortures the old robot with
details of Juliet's suicide and Logan's
overdose and he leaves him to degrade
this leads to Williams dark killing
spree that we see in season 1
terrorizing Maeve when
was a homesteader and her daughter and
his new interest in the maze and his
journey with Lawrence and Teddy and his
encounter with Dolores remember all that
good fun stuff now all that was set in
the present-day
2052 along with the other season one
events Maeve's awakening with felix and
Sylvester and the del o Strama with LC
and Stubbs and Charlotte Teresa and Lea
and of course old man Ford's Medellin
Medellin that takes us to the main
events - season two they take place over
the course of two weeks and it begins in
the immediate aftermath of Dolores
killing Ford in the ensuing massacre at
the gala in Bernards timeline a he
escapes with Charlotte but they get
split up and Bernard ends up with Elsie
together these two learned the park is
collecting data on human guests
meanwhile Dolores goes on her own deadly
campaign with Teddy Angela and the other
soldiers to get Abernathy before
Charlotte does Maeve Hector Armitage
leave Felix's Wester end up in Shogun
world and Maeve learns that she can
control other hosts non-verbally and all
these events go down over the course of
the first week several threads actually
converge in episode 6 when the train
that Dolores and Teddy are on crashes
into the Mesa facility while this is all
going on William continues on what he
perceives to be a new game from Ford
this eventually runs him into his
daughter Emily who escaped from the Raj
William who's kind of losing it this
season ends up killing his daughter
thinking she's a host meanwhile team
Dolores overwhelms team Charlotte
Dolores walks away with the encryption
key from Abernathy's head and then it's
a race to the forge where the virtual
Eden awaits hosts but Dolores sees this
as another false promise and she tries
to wipe it out but Bernard shoots it
before she can and then the forge floods
and Charlotte shoots else even Bernard
replaces Charlotte with a host version
of her with Dolores his coat and then he
scrambles his memory and leave himself
on the beach now again all that
transpired over two weeks and this
catches us up to the season two timeline
B from Bernard in which the confused
Bernard now joins the dello security
team as they piece together what
happened and their investigation leads
into the forge where Charlotte / Dolores
activates and then she ends up escaping
the park now sometime after this the
episodes final scene shows us Charlotte
Dolores and Bernard all back in their
own host bodies outside of the park in
the real world in what kind of looks
like Bernards old house now they're
planning their next moves and of course
the post-credits scene
place in the distant future showing a
host version of William in a fidelity
test conducted by a host version of its
daughter in the forge ruins now yes I
just met through a lot of plot points
that you might still have questions
about and there's a very good chance I
covered those questions in my other
Indian explained video so go check that
out and now that we have a good sense of
win all the storylines go down in
relation to each other
a question for you guys do you want
Westworld season 3 to move the timeline
forward into the future closer to the
time of the post-credits scene or
explore deeper into the past filling in
the early years with arnold bernhard and
williams ears within the park comment
down below with your thoughts or tweet
me directly at a vast and follow our
channel at new rockstars for updates on
our videos like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rock stars
for deep dives into West's world and
Game of Thrones and other obsessive
dissections of the Nolan brothers
nonlinear storytelling because guys
stories aren't just stories they're
puzzles
thanks for watching bye
[Music]